I really don't like the Alcoholics
Anonymous concept of every morning
waking up and saying I am an alcoholic
or whatever because what it does is it
puts it at the Forefront of their mind
they literally label themselves every
morning is having this problem when
somebody who's not an alcoholic just
doesn't think about it they don't think
I'm an alcoholic I have to fight not
drinking every day they just don't think
about it I think it's exiting the
equation altogether but then wouldn't
you get just people not caring at all
yes yeah and there are different ways to
take that some people see that as very
very self-serving which it might be but
to the same degree like you are released
from the chains of the expectations of
others if you can exit the equation of
like labeling yourself and then just
doing because what else will you do
while you are alive it creates some
levels of Freedom that allow for clarity
of thought and also for the ability to
take risks that most people can't take